Ecarte-toi, parce que ça risque de faire trop mal !
Noooooon !
Attention !
On les a tous tué.
Noé, chéri, joue avec Lila.
Tu sais c'est un peu comme ta soeur.
Vous faites partie de la même famille maintenant.
Allez, soyez sage.
On se débrouille très bien tous les deux hein.
On a besoin de personne nous !
Pas vrai Noé ?
Bon...
On se fait un Jenga ou on va jouer aux petites voitures ?
Noé met toi à couvert !
Je m'occupe de lui.
T'es qui ?!
Euh... je...
François Poisson.
Qu'est ce que tu fous dans ma chambre ?
Alors...
Je voudrais pas te contrarier hein.
Mais je pense que désormais ça sera notre chambre.
Vu qu'avec Lila on va s'installer ici.
Comment ça ?
Ben...
On est une famille maintenant.
Une famille ?
Certainement pas !
Qu'est ce que t'as ?
Tu m'as fait vachement mal à la gorge hein.
Oui enfin excuse moi mais on a pas mal nous.
Comment ça "nous" ?
Bah nous, les amis imaginaires.
On a pas mal.
Les amis imaginaires ? C'est quoi ça ?
Oh non...
Ne me dis pas que tu penses que tu es réel ?
Bon...
C'est qui tes parents ?
Un chevalier et une mangouste.
Et y a rien qui te choque là ?
Les chevalier ça se marie pas.
Ok.
Qu'est ce que tu fais comme travail ?
Ça dépend.
Ça dépend des jours, ça dépend des après-midi.
Parfois je suis pirate.
A des moments je suis caissière.
Même que des moments je fais comme le papa de Lila...
J'écris des chiffres sur des feuilles.
T'es comptable quoi.
Alors, pas tout à fait hein.
Parce que nous avec Lila on dit chiffrier.
Même que tu peux aller lui demander.
Elle sait qui je suis.
Oui, mais c'est normal.
Puisque c'est elle qui t'a créé.
C'est comme moi.
C'est Noé qui m'a créé.
Attends...
Tu peux répéter ?
Tiens, ça par exemple !
T'as déjà vu un chiffrier avec une main fusée ?
Oui, non, c'est vrai, y en a pas des masses.
Voilà !
Parce que ça n'existe pas !
Tu n'existes pas Poisson !
Non, j'existe pas...
Bah non !
Non mais...
Moi non plus j'existe pas.
Je voulais pas te dire ça comme ça.
Moi aussi tu sais au début j'ai eu du mal à l'accepter.
Et puis bah...
En plus toi t'as de la chance, t'as une main fusée, regarde !
Elle est vachement bien hein.
Moi franchement j'adorerai en avoir une.
Regarde tu peux faire plein de truc avec ça !
Après là j'ai pas d'idée mais je...
Attends !
Les amis imaginaires ils sont là pour jouer avec les enfants quand ils sont seuls ?
Voilà, exactement !
Ouais mais si Noé et Lila ils se mettent à jouer ensemble...
Nous on sert plus à rien ?
Bah non.
Mais si on sert à rien...
Ça veut dire qu'on va disparaitre.
Exactement !
On va disparaitre !
On va disparaitre.
Faut absolument qu'on les empêche de jouer ensemble.
D'accord mais on peut pas faire ça...
C'est pas bien.
Attends, laisse moi trouver une idée.
Un idée...
Une idée...
Je sais !
On a qu'à faire un gros trou dans le pull de Lila.
Avec un grand ciseau !
Comme ça, ça sera Noé qui se fera engueuler.
Non, non, non, ça c'est pas une bonne idée ça !
On a qu'à faire un shampoing avec de la confiture à Lila...
Et puis après on lui coupe les cheveux avec les ciseaux !
Et ça c'est marrant !
Oh bah non ! Pas les cheveux.
On a qu'à démolir le château fort en Lego.
Tu touches pas au château fort !
On a mis trois jours à le monter, ça a été une galère !
Ou alors...
On demande aux enfants de faire manger de la mayonnaise au hamster.
Ah oui mais non ça marchera pas.
Parce que si c'est les deux qui le font ils seront complices et donc...
Je te présente François Poisson.
Il est drôle, il est grand...
Il a un tutu et un bras fusée.
Ça c'est moi.
Ah moi aussi Monsieur Barney il en a un.
Oh yes !
Il a un tutu.
Ah merde.
On va jouer aux pirates dehors ?
Ok !
Barney !
Ça y est c'est la fin !
Ouais...
Je suis en train de disparaitre là.
Regarde !
Je sens plus mes jambes !
Ça y est mais là c'est fini, ils sont en train de jouer ensemble !
C'est fini pour nous, regarde !
En même temps y a une certaine logique hein.
Tu sais nous les amis imaginaires on est là pour accompagner...
Je disparais là, regarde !
Amuser...
Regarde !
Puis disparaitre.
Barney !
Regarde !
Notre mission est terminée camarade.
Game over Poisson.
Vous venez jouer avec nous ?